well one of our Kelly's accusers says
she has proof that the grammy-winning
singer tried to intimidate her into
staying silent about his alleged abuse
faith rogers answered questions at a
news conference yesterday before meeting
with police in New York in an interview
you'll see only on CBS this morning
Rogers and her attorney Gloria Allred
talk with dareka Duncan about what she
has endured since she first spoke out
against the singer Jericka good morning
good morning bianna we first met faith
Rogers last May she told us about the
alleged mental sexual and verbal abuse
she says she went through during a
relationship with our Kelly when she was
just 19 years old her lawsuit filed last
year claims our Kelly knowingly gave her
an STD and since coming forward Rodgers
says the R&B singer has threatened her
and her family it's been over seven
months since we first interviewed you
about your are Kelly allegations how was
your life changed the first time we
spoke it was negative now I have more
support but I'm finding my strength and
I'm pressing forward with everything I
need to do faith Rogers is pressing
forward by coming forward about alleged
abuse she says she suffered at the hands
of R&B singer R Kelly backed by famed
attorney Gloria Allred the 21 year old
spoke to New York police Monday and
unveiled a threatening letter allegedly
written by Kelly last October mr. Kelly
appears to have been engaging in a
campaign of intimidation and retaliation
in the notarized letter to a lawyer
representing Rodgers which she says also
contained compromising photos of her
Kelly allegedly wrote if she persists in
court actions she will be subjected to
public opinion and demanded Rodgers
provide test results proving the origin
of her STD claim the letter also said
Kelly would request ten personal mail
witnesses testifying about Rodgers sex
life it just validates the monster that
he is that's what it does I realized
that's his defense but his defense is
only revealing his true colors Kelly's
attorney told us the letter is a fake
saying our Kelly can't read write or
type he didn't send any letter
it was our Kelly
and who are you to tell are killing now
Rogers is one of several accusers who
appeared in the doc you series surviving
are Kelly which chronicled years of
accusations against the singer Allred
now represents three women including
Rogers who say Kelly victimized them
this has been building for quite a while
but now it's approaching a tsunami for
mr. Kelly and now because we have young
women of courage like faith those who
are watching and listening are needing
to pay attention we also spoke with
Rogers mother who says she hopes other
women will come forward you're a
pastor's wife I am you guys talk about
forgiveness I'm sure a church absolutely
is there any way you could ever see
yourself forgiving our Kelly can I
forgive him absolutely he needs help
not only mental help he needs spiritual
help do you think he should be in jail
absolutely absolutely
Rogers attorneys say they don't know if
criminal charges are imminent but Rogers
believes Kelly's days in the limelight
are numbered if our Kelly is watching
this right now what would you say to him
better think of something quick running
out of time well Kelly has denied all
wrongdoing and claims all sexual acts
with his accusers were consensual
investigators in Georgia and reportedly
are reportedly looking into some abuse
claims but the local DA would not
comment now more artists are distancing
themselves from our Kelly Celine Dion
and chance the rapper have reportedly
pulled their music collaborations with
him from streaming services and you know
we've reached out to his manager I've
actually spoken to him a number of times
he has no comment I think people are
interested in hearing from him yeah
because there are so many people coming
out against him and these artists are
saying you know what I don't want
anything to do and he continues to deny
all of the allegations and says that
it's consensual but thank you drumbeat
against him is really getting louder and
louder it is thank you Jim yep